hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to cozy I am trapped alone
in this car with an air freshener it
hardly feels necessary at a forest well
I don't know exactly where I am I just
need to make sure my uncle's okay then I
can leave so it's a point-and-click
style adventure but it's a horror game
so don't be fooled by what you see in
front of you in the relaxing calm music
I'm sure that eventually that eventually
hell will unleash itself soon so we need
to go the wind is bitter and cold so we
need to go all the way to my uncle's
house and we've made our way here and
the lights are out oh look
key under the rock how about I use that
on the door all right surprising huh oh
well that's that's not exactly a lovely
piece of painting it looks like someone
falling down the stairs and blood coming
out of the mouth and generally disarray
well this is it da [ __ ] oh okay already
then I don't know why that was there why
is there a tiny alcove at the bottom of
the [ __ ] Hey hi why is there so much
wind whistling through this hallway
why is necessary oh hello can I get
myself a glass of water okay so I gotta
find my uncle so somehow I've no idea
how I'm gonna find my uncle maybe in
this dark alcove oh good old moldy
pillow nothing else rather damp I'd
rather not know with what
grace hi oh hi hi ho ho hi oh hi oh hi
he's dead okay oh right oh boy I should
get help
yeah no joke I should get help I should
get the heck out of here
radical yet classical approach to the
rectangle oh such an interesting
observation to make after you find your
uncle Ted Swedish side table only $9.99
okay all right then I don't think
there's a phone here ah not hungry right
now yeah my uncle is dead oh boy okay so
what do I need to do I need I need to
get the heck out of here right do I need
to go find somebody oh hi
pile of loose snow interred within the
remains of a snowman the doors frozen
shut so I need I need to find some way
to get in the shed I guess but why the
heck don't I just go get help
what how did this happen there's no way
I'm getting in with all the snow I don't
know maybe it's snowing maybe I'm a
freaking idiot okay empty glass too bad
there isn't anything to drink okay so if
I take the glass I could eventually find
something to put in the glass yeah
[Music]
oh boy Karen said the boards are
blocking the way so if I can find a way
in here which I'm assuming if I can get
into the shed I'll find something to be
able to get in there behind the board's
that should be able to help me but I
still gotta find something to light it
with hmm pack some snow into the glass
okay that's good so maybe if I get if I
put that oh I can ah
so I've got some water now so I can go
and I can put this on the kettle and
then I'll get some warm water snow was
melted into nice warm water so now I
have warm water and I can go outside and
I should be able to melt the lock on the
shed yeah that makes sense
yes melted off the ice the door should
open now ah no one's been in here for
years
hammer lighter fluid and a shovel so I
might be able to use that shovel to
clear my car let's see lighter fluid so
if I find something to light Oh
it's getting dark I should leave well I
wanna leave oh god I don't like that
okay so maybe okay the shovel broke but
at least the snow is gone
run-of-the-mill stick doors been bashed
in I'll need to pry it open has the door
been passed and was I just flailing with
the shovel I've no idea I need to learn
some self goddamn control okay so maybe
if I like the stick on fire stick won't
stay lit so I don't like okay so what I
got to do is I gotta go doused the stick
in lighter fluid and then
poor saman something needs to absorb it
uh so I need like a rag yeah
alright you know what I think I gotta go
visit my uncle that is unpleasant Pam
should pry the board up from the edges
okay did it pieces of board pried it off
the wall yeah okay all right
snip snip there goes your fingertip
antipsychotics and extra absorbent so if
I take the stick wrap some bandages on
the stick okay we're good there my
uncle's still gonna be there hi [ __ ] off
with you what was that all about well
yeah just look rather not see that again
okay didn't mean to go that way then
also why was he groaning if he's dead
okay so either way I've got I've got the
rag I need to go soak it - I need to go
soak it in the lighter fluid in the back
of the shed and then I should be able to
light it on fire and then burn the whole
goddamn house down because I don't want
to be here anymore everything's horrible
also where did the Snowman bits go the
Snowman bits are gone that's not good
that's not good at all
all right maybe torch all right so I
should be able to go down here and see
ah good a plastic broom stick it's been
broken in half label reads Christmas
decorations full of odds and ends ah
there we go crowbar okay I got a crowbar
so now I can pry open my car door and
get the fudge out of here
maybe finally I can get my car what's
going on my keys are missing
oh no I have to find my keys well where
am I gonna find that mysteriously in my
uncle's place why is a loading screen
all weird and slow now oh I don't know
like that uncle
oh why is it like that now Oh uncle's
gone Oh bye Oh No
ah boy oh boy uncle ain't there no more
uncle Nate there it can only mean uncle
ain't so dead maybe this is all just a
practical joke and my uncle's just a
funny funny guy where would my keys be
have no idea I mean it wouldn't be in
the it wouldn't be in life I [ __ ]
[ __ ] off I saw that oh boy oh boy I saw
that oh and then the paintings gotten
worse there anything under here that I
should know about
maybe I should take this with me yeah
you know what I'm just gonna get out of
here probably for the best
my uncle is very weird can't stop
shaking maybe cuz it's cold maybe
because you're about to die oh boy
I'm not gonna get out of here hey hi oh
that's the end of it okay I guess am i
dead is dead what I am I think I might
be dead oh boy alrighty then that was
that was not so bad that was pretty good
for being a short horror game it did
create a lot of ambience I'm just like
kind of like ah the ending was a bit
anticlimactic I was hoping for something
a bit more substantial than that but
still pretty good had me on the edge of
my seat for quite a bit there that was
not bad I just wish there was more to it
than that
it reminded me of uh of a kind of script
welders style of making these pixelated
point-and-click adventure games but
still very good so to the developer I'd
like to see more of this I bet there
could have been a lot more made out of
this and maybe there was some secrets I
didn't find but I'm pretty sure I got
through the whole story so let me know
what you guys think down the comments
below and thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you
in the next video bye-bye